second day of the symposium is dedicated
to how can we get involved and make an
impact in data and life sciences
so to introduce that i would now like to
invite mr ilya brodsky mr ilya brodsky
is one of the co-founder and ceo of pine
biotech
he has facilitated and managed
collaborations with researchers at
stanford ucsf louisiana state university
tulane and other academic and pharma r d
teams as well mr elia brodsky oversees
the research projects and manages the
development of the prototype preparation
of the relevant data projects and
implementation of the system for the
need of students and teachers that the
project is designed for over to you mr
elia
thank you so much and before we begin
maybe we could launch the poll
so
you will launch the ball
uh yes just a second elia uh can you
just launch the poll after your talk
okay
it's asking me to sign in i'm not
signing from the official account i
think
okay
all right thank you everyone and great
to be here today
and then you thank you so much for the
introduction
um so i'm excited to be here on our
second day
um and as sonalik already mentioned we
will go on to
speak about how one can get involved in
bioinformatics in a more serious way to
contribute to the field as it becomes
more dynamic more impactful
with many real and important
applications across many domains in life
science research and industry and
before
we begin i want to briefly uh share an
overview of what we covered last
day in multiple sessions that we had
we had a lot of great speakers
panel discussions uh project
presentations so it was a really
exciting opportunity to be together for
all of us
so first of all we heard about the omics
logic programs in india
india is one of the most populous
countries in the world
and is a growing economy that is
producing millions of graduates every
year
overall india has over 1 000
universities with 42 000 colleges and
over 11 000 standalone institutions in
the country that is catering to over 38
million students and so what our team is
doing is working there since 2019
partnering with institutions in the
country
and
addressing some of the gaps in
bioinformatics education by offering
research opportunities to students that
are working with faculty on various data
science projects across many life
science domains and building a pathway
for students to work in biotechnology
pharma and bioinformatic industries
and
after working with thousands of students
from around the country our team shared
lessons learned and offered an important
perspective moving forward with some new
initiatives that have undergone major
changes as a result of this pandemic
one key insight
actually came out of the panel
discussion
where we heard about the challenges and
opportunities in bioinformatics in india
so we heard from dr raghav and professor
radana that offered their insights in
academic research as well as government
initiatives and urgent need for data
science in healthcare and biotechnology
industry in india
we also heard from our team in africa
where our mix logic training has been
launched in 2019
sub-saharan africa is home to more than
one billion people
half of whom will be under the age of 25
by 2050. so it is a very diverse
continent that offers a lot of human and
natural resources
and they have the potential to yield
inclusive growth and importantly
eradicate some of the challenges
including
poverty and
various types of infectious diseases
and so what we heard was
about how
many of those
areas of research are being addressed
using bioinformatics
we heard from dr anita ganza from ghana
dr vokitori from nigeria dr adrian lusa
from south africa and some of our team
members mr adelu
and mr hamza that have worked with
numerous students in this region
overall it was an insightful day where
we got a global perspective so i want to
thank all of the speakers who have
shared their perspective on what going
what was going on in africa and india
and here are some of my personal
takeaways so first of all there is a
pressing need to review annotate and
improve data quality the both the data
that is currently available and some of
the future data sets that will be shared
we heard from dr raghav how his
group of students and himself are
working to make that process more
effective and offer a lot of resources
for those learning bioinformatics
we heard about the urgent need of
training in bioinformatics and data
science for those who are working on
important challenges in medicine public
health and other domains
we we heard about bridge programs that
connect students with authentic research
opportunities and with industry careers
and hello
opportunities for students and
researchers to be involved in many
fields of research working together with
mentors and leaders in these fields
after that we heard about some of the
exciting developments in the world of
bioinformatics research and applications
to various challenges like byron
that's the last
uh yeah sorry i had to uh mute all the
particip
okay
thank you
sorry about that so we heard about um
some of the speakers that are working on
bioinformatics and developing new
approaches that are used by thousands of
researchers and students and so here are
my takeaways from those talks
uh first of all there's a growing
complexity of omics data including
single cell
okay including single cell sequencing
large scale genomic whole genome
sequencing data and important questions
about the junk
non-coding sequences or the dark part of
the genome where important regulatory
elements are being defined we heard
about
we heard about experimental data that
can reveal a snapshot of biological
activity
but to see the whole picture there's the
need for integration of multi-omics data
time estimation and mathematical models
that can be simulated to understand what
these biological snapshots can tell us
about trajectories and time
we also heard about the way this
pandemic has spurred active research in
many areas leading to new approaches for
genomic surveillance
novel types of vaccines and even new
interventions based on our understanding
of viral
evolution and finally we heard about a
new or maybe an old field called
astrobiology
first of all we heard about how it has
contributed to the development of
genomic technologies in general and what
data sets are available
and heard about some of the novel
findings coming from the study of
extremophiles that are useful
on
on her on here on earth with many
applications in biotechnology
and these talks were accompanied with a
panel discussion on the topic of omics
data and associated methods of analysis
so we heard about
the perspectives on how this field of
bioinformatics is playing a major role
in various research projects from dr
raul and dino from the university of
california san francisco
dr sona vasudevan from georgetown
university who's also going to be
speaking today we heard about dr lena
brodsky from the talbot bioinformatics
research center
at the university of haifa
and dr casulis from the national
association of idea principal
investigators he also will be speaking
today
and finally
we heard from dr laura harris from
michigan state university so what these
speakers highlighted was the role that
the students can play
and some opportunities for early career
scientists in many areas including
virology microbiology biotechnology and
as well as clinical and biomedical
research projects to utilize
bioinformatics and get involved in many
other projects
so briefly um i want to tell you uh what
is the reason that we are organizing
this symposium and how can we transition
from some of the topics that we heard
about yesterday and go on to the topic
of today's
sessions so the onyx logic programs
which are operated by pine biotech
are designed to provide training and
bioinformatics that enable independent
research guided by mentors and peer
example it is also to develop a growing
community that shares a passion for
data-driven research and many
applications of citizen science so it is
really a goal of ours to build this
community and part of that process is
this symposium
and ultimately our goal is to enable
students clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology in life and data sciences and
so the way that we do this
is by offering training programs that
provide access to high performance
computing mentorship and training in
bioinformatics and data science for
biological data
the training modules are offered through
the omixlogic portal where you can
register for free and explore
asynchronous modules on various types of
rmx data exercises in pipeline building
coding in r and python as well as offer
a view of case studies based on
peer-reviewed publications from top
research journals
so the link and to the portal that you
can explore today as well is right here
um
what these projects are organized into
learning paths for oncology infectious
diseases neuroscience and agriculture in
each learning path we use examples that
illustrate major trends and novel
applications of omics data in particular
field and since the domain of
bioinformatics is so dynamic we are
relying on collaborators in all of these
fields to navigate updated topics and
developments we work closely with our
partners at the talbot bioinformatics
research center where the team is making
many algorithms for data analysis easy
to use for non-bioinformaticians using
the tbion for platform which offers a
user-friendly interface for many
commonly used methods on phylodynamics
analysis of gene expression alignment to
reference genomes analysis of structural
data and variant calling and so this t
binaural platform is also available
on this link
okay sorry about that
there we go
so one of our programs that we
highlighted throughout the symposium is
the research fellowship where students
can design an independent research
project and work in groups with mentors
that guide them to complete their
research using bioinformatics relying on
publicly available data sets and working
with mentors that are provided through
our program and through our network
many of the research fellows have been
working for the past several months to
complete their projects and share them
for the poster session that you see
today
you will find the projects that they
have submitted organized on this link